the human brain is one of the most
sophisticated organs in the world a
supercomputer made of billions of
neurons that processes and controls all
of our senses thoughts and actions but
there was something Charles Darwin found
even more impressive the brain of an ant
which he called one of the most
marvelous atoms of matter in the world
if you find it hard to believe that
something so tiny could have a complex
brain you're not alone in his project to
classify and describe all living things
Swedish naturalist Carl Linnaeus assumed
insects had no brains at all he was
wrong
but understandably so insect brains are
not only minuscule but in many respects
they function differently than our own
one of the most noticeable differences
is that an insect that loses its head
can still walk scratch itself breathe
and even fly this is because while our
nervous system works like a monarchy
with the brain calling the shots the
insect nervous system works more like a
decentralized Federation many insect
activities like walking or breathing are
coordinated by clusters of neurons also
known as ganglia along their bodies
together with the brain these local
ganglia form the insect nervous system
while an insect can do a lot with just
its local ganglia the brain is still
crucial for its survival an insect's
brain lets it perceive the world through
sight and smell it also chooses suitable
mates remembers locations of food
sources and hives regulates
communication and even coordinates
navigation over huge distances and this
vast diversity of behaviors is
controlled by an organ the size of the
head of a pin with less than 1 million
neurons compared to our 86 billion but
even though the insect brain is
organized very differently from ours
there are some striking similarities for
example most insects have smell
detectors on their antennae similar to
those found in human noses and our
primary olfactory brain regions look and
function rather similarly with clusters
of neurons activated and deactivated in
precise timing to code for specific
sense scientists have been astonished by
these similarities because insects and
humans are not very closely related
in fact our last common ancestor was a
simple worm like creature that
more than 500 million years ago so how
did we end up with such similar brain
structures when our evolution took
almost entirely different paths
scientists call this phenomenon
convergent evolution
it's the same principle behind birds
bats and bees separately evolving wings
similar selective pressures can cause
natural selection to favor the same
evolutionary strategy in species with
vastly different evolutionary pasts by
studying the comparison between insect
and human brains scientists can thus
understand which of our brain functions
are unique and which are general
solutions to evolutionary problems but
this is not the only reason scientists
are fascinated by insect brains their
small size and simplicity makes it
easier to understand exactly how neurons
work together in the brain this is also
valuable for engineers who study the
insect brain to help design control
systems for everything from cell flying
airplanes to tiny search-and-rescue
roach BOTS so size and complexity are
not always the most impressive things
the next time you try to swat a fly take
a moment to marvel at the efficiency of
its tiny nervous system as it outsmarts
your fancy brain
you